نداءات عده واجهتها منظمه الصحه العالميه
من مخاطر مقاومه المضادات الحيويه على
الصحه بسبب الطاعات العشوائي لها المضادات
اليوم اصبحت هذه التحذيرات في محلها بعد
نجاحت البكتيريا مرض السرطان واصبحت في
المركز الثاني اكبر قاتل بعد القلب في
العالم الاف الباحثين اجتمعوا في دراسه
تابعه لمؤسسه بيل جيت الطبيه وخلصوا لانه
يمكن ان تعزى وفاه واحده من اصل كل ثمانيه
حالات وفاه عالميا الى الامراض الناجمه عن
الاصابه بالبكتيريا تشيروا دراسه ايضا
لانه من بين 30 نوعا من البكتيريا
المدروسه تعتبر خمسه منها مسؤوله عن اكثر
من نصف الوفيات في العالم
على كل حال الظاهره بالارقام معك يا علاء
اليك
رصدت منظمه الصحه العالميه الاسباب
الرئيسيه للوفاه حول العالم احتل مرض
السكتات القلبيه وضيق الشرايين المرتبه
الاولى كاشد الامراض فتكا ويعد مسؤول عن
16% من اجمالي الوفيات في العالم
السكته الدماغيه في المرتبه الثانيه
وتتسبب بوفاه حوالي احد عشر في المئه حول
العالم والسبب الرئيسي لها هو ارتفاع ضغط
الدم في المرتبه الثالثه ده الانسداد
الرئوي المزمن حيث تسبب في ثلاثه ملايين
و230,000 حاله وفاه وهو ما نسبته 6% من
اجمالي عدد الوفيات امراض القناه التنفسيه
السفلى اصبحت في المرتبه الرابعه بعد ان
كانت اشد الامراض الساريه فاتكا في العالم
الحالات المرضيه في المواليد تاتي في
المركز الخامس لكنها ايضا تشهد تراجعا
عالميا كبيرا
[موسيقى]
فيديو ولاول مره ينورنا من دبي استشاري
الامراض الباطنيه والامراض يا دكتور صباح
الحلو يا دكتور
الله كريم
تخيلي هذه فيها اوكي اكثر من اثنين فاصله
خمسه كيلو جرام بكتيريا
تتخيلي هذا كله عايش جوه جسمنا هذه
البكتيريا كلها عايشه جوه جسمنا هذه
البكتيريا من يوم ما احنا ناخذ لها مضادات
هي حقتنا هي تسوي لنا اشياء كثيره في
جسمنا كويس كل ما ناخذ لها مضاد تقوم
تتالم تقوم الا الله
اوكي تقوم بعد كده لا سمح الله جاء التهاب
في البول ما عاد نلاقي مضاد نستخدمه يعني
بس دكتور خلينا نفهم نحنا صرنا كانه اخر
فتره على يمين وشمال عم ناخذ انت بيوتك هل
صار هذا هو السبب انه بدل ما تكون تقاوم
هذه البكتيريا صارت تؤدي الى بكتيريا ضاره
في المستقبل
هذا هو التفسير العلمي الحقيقي احنا سرنا
نعطي مضاد يمين يسار كل واحد سخن يوم اخذ
مضاد مضبوط وللاسف الشديد احيانا المريض
يطالب به واحيانا الطبيب يعطي بدون داعي
للاسف الشديد احنا يقولوا عندي عمره كده
رحت احد قال لك عندي انفلونزا
وحديكي موبايل كيف
هو فيروس كيف هتديني بعد
علشان احميك من لا يجيك بكتيريا هذا مخالف
للعلم ما ينفع هذا الكلام اوكي
اخر ثلاث سنوات لم تنتج البكتيريا واحد
البشريه واحد مضاد حيوي في العالم جديد
طيب وين السؤال يا دكتور لماذا فشلت
البشريه في مواجهه البكتيريا
اي تخيلي انه احنا كانت تسال بكتيريا على
بال مثلا اول مثلا البنسلين اخذت اكثر من
10 سنوات ولا اكثر عشان تسوي مقاومه الان
اشد انواع المضادات اللي اكتشفت البشريه
في الخمسه ولا سبع سنين اخذ اثنين ثمانيه
الى تسعه شهور عشان تسوي مقاومه
تخيلي قلبه كثير جدا ذكيه والبكتيريا
مقاومه للمضادات بشكل جدا سريع اها طيب
اذا هالقد دكتور نزار البكتيريا جدا ذكيه
ممكن البكتيريا الضاره يوما ما تتغلب على
البكتيريا النافعه لانه احنا مثلا في
بكتيريا نافعه للتوازن الغذائي ولحمه
امراض الفطريه وغيره ههه
انت تكتب النافع حقك وما تسمعي دحين ناس
كتير
ما تخلص من البكتيريا حقهم انا اشرب كل
يوم
البكتيريا هذه النافعه حقت تساعدنا في
اشياء كثيره من الهضم للمناعه لاشياء
كثيره تؤثر فيها كثره اخدك للمضاد مو بس
انت تسوي البكتيريا مقاومه المضادات لا
انت كمان ياثر على الاشياء كثير جوا جسمك
طيب دكتور تحدثنا عن مواجهه البكتيريا
ماذا عن الوقايه منها كيف نحمي انفسنا من
البكتيريا وهل المضادات الحيويه وتطعيم
والحلوه
اول شيء لازم ياكد التطعيمات مهمه
للفيروسات
[موسيقى]
والبكتيريا اللي مؤثر فيها هو المضاد
الحيوي اذا انت تبغي تحمي نفسك من انك ما
تجيلك مشاكل من البكتيريا بس يبغى لك تغسل
يدها فقط
ما يبغى لك اكثر من كده لكن اذا كنت تبغى
تنسي البكتيريا حقتك هذه المقاومه كل اللي
عليك انك ما تاخذ مضاد يعني بالحقيقه
الموضوع اذا انت كنت بتنفع نفسك تنفع
عائلتك ما تدي مضاد لنفسك طيب دكتور نزار
انت بلشت في بدايه الحديث قلنا قد ايه في
بكتيريا باجسامنا بحجم ملعب تنس بس انا
كمان اليوم بدي لما كل ما اروح عند دكتور
اودي ابني السؤال انه بدنا نشوف اذا
فايروس
سؤال مره كويس ناس كثير ما يسالوا هو هذه
بكتيريا يعني لها دلائل في التحاليل ولا
لا لانه حقيقه التحاليل تدي شويه الدلالات
انه هذه بكتيريا ما هو فيروس واذا كان
فيروس خلاص نصبر عليه
المشكله العوائل ما تبغى تصبر على السخونه
والسخونه ما هي شيء سيء السخونه هي نعمه
من عند الله السخونه جاتني دحين لما انت
بتطبخ الاكل وما تطبخيه علشان تقتل
البكتيريا البطل
علشان كده اذا كان عندنا اي فايروس ولا
بكتيريا يقوم الله يرفع السخونه جوه جسمنا
عشان تموت قبل البشريه ما كان في مضادات
حيويه الله خلق العلاج داخلنا ارفع
السخونه تموت
بكل بساطه السخونه ما هي شيء بالطال هو
السخونه وهبوط الضغط اللي بطال السخونه
لما تكون عند الاطفال اللي اقل من خمس
سنوات هو اللي بطال السخونه والجفاف هو
اللي بطال السخونه كسخونه ما فيها مشكله
40 زي 39 زي 38 لجلسه يومين ثلاثه اربعه
سبعه ما في مشكله لان هذا نداء من الجسم
انه يبغاك انك انت تقاوم اللي داخلك بكل
بساطه احنا ما يبغاني نستعجل دائما لما
يجوا الاطفال عندهم سخونه نديهم مخفضات
الحراره ونشربهم ماء هذا اهم حاجه مو لازم
ياكله مو لازم انك انت تتاكلهم المهم انك
تشربهم او تشربهم شيء في سكر بس مو لازم
انك تاكلهم لانه لما الواحد يصير عنده
سخونه الامعاء ما تمشي بسرعه اذا انت
اكلته ممكن
اهدى عليه خليه هو مسخن شربه
وجودك معنا حفله
الله يخليك